Trent Frederick has a milestone game and the game
is on the two teams starting their fourth lines
Derek forward rattles it beer too to Shen
Kirk a good save by Soros and Sherwood is
in transition forward back sis and scores
a onetime off forward stick it teed it up
for sis who has his second goal the D Forman
attack and you're right Jack just that little
stick position of forber it was generally a good
play disrupts that pass attempt but as it turns
out now it's a perfect Mar is out forber wall
pass Maran a save by Soros he didn't have one
a some big plays by the Bruins penalty killing
it started with the CH Charlie Coy faceof win
it take a lot of that 14 seconds off the clock
to Maran penalty then the great block was a nice
play entering the offensive zone Evangelista
to nist behind the back Novak and Evangelista
and swim makes a good save round f where to be
he's deep in his own Zone you can see him right
there in the replay circling in the opposite
direction now he's nowhere near the blue line
so that's a quick re-entry good recognition
Evangelista takes that Saka clean entry van
reke sistens couldn't clear makavo shot bounces
off Fabro leg Maran to Van R he scores his first
as a Boston bro it's not how it's not how it's
How many I think that's one winning on Fabro
didn't it yep inside ice yeah he's very good in
and around the net scores the majority of his
goals from 15 fet or closer they work the low
play he's looking to make a pass cross to the
other side of the ice to P if that not there
maybe a touch to zaka who's approaching the
net but the Bruins get the good bounce that they
needed Fabro going down trying to take away that
pass maoy to grizzli Frederick gains the line
geeki trying to feed Frederick padra geeki a
net J vr's all Mater UNH beat number one
in the ation be D it was a good look by
lindol looking for Charlie Cole on
that crossy pass in the offensive
zone siss out battles grizzli Philip forsberg in
front just look on the stick poock
has a breakaway and sorrow swabs
him taton Kirk grizzli whistles it just wide
of the post across the grain glub side that
was his first and then how about tonight
the same two combined after some quality
penalty killing by Bost and Luchi steps
on the ice finds POS all by himself two
superstars forsberg toosi almost an own goal and
San kicks it out Barry's shot blocked in the slot
and swiming RS scramble moments advantage to
the power play because you really don't have
any structure here and if that puck squirts
through to the offensive team as it does good
shot blocked there by Carlo but this one right
here O'Reilly that's a great read by swim and
Big Time stop terier pomino oh a point blank
save by San off of Nova back on the doorstep
as the penalty expires but DNA can't keep
it in pck a save by S poock gets a penalty
shot poock the serpentine rout scores
you could have hung a hacker chip from
the corner of the goal and it would have had a
hole in it what he puts this Puck almost behind
the that is incredible put a put it not
off his hip Jack behind his hip and then
just whips it on the follow through to read for
the golender is he whipping at my blocker side
is he going over my glove is he going five
hole I got no idea and he just whistles it
Yi Yosi tees it up tip [Applause] scores look
like siss again siss has put Nashville into
a tie three goals in two games for Colton
sistens not much there in my opinion anyway
good job by Nashville to get the goal tender
pull maintain possession move the puck around
show some patience and finally get the
shot that they were looking for which is
the middle of the offensive zone from
the blue line with an open man in the
slot Charlie Coyle has played five 51
at even strength and 551 at short-handed
strength an offensive minded defenseman swings
it in front and it rattles to Swan Square to
the puck not reaching Charlie Coyle K Coyle
got that puck are was already thinking and
moving forward he was already pivoting to go
get the p coil on the tip and it goes off the
apron and into the Nashville bench a couple of
real good looks both players missing the net the
first one was zaka the second one's going
to be P nice play there's that little pump
fake by zaka in the bumper slides it over it's a
little bit behind P knock for the ideal one time
that might throw off your aim a little bit the
flex on the shaft of the stick he slowo H maoy
[Music] scores Puck seemed to change
direction and James Greenstein has his
second Puck retrieval off a draw so critical
Pak able to reach in but you got to have that
shot the threat of the shot with a purpose
from on the top of the umbrella well they
try to get aoy to use that shot more and
more often continue to add it to your game
and allow you to make more plays from that
position particularly on the man Advantage
but he had his eyes up he was looking for
a stick gains the line Carlo a good step
up Loco with Lich lco sa by Sorrows nice pass
by Luchi again that back s GI has a stick in
there forsburg to or rilly Yosi with
less than 10 the shot doesn't make
it to goal one timer By Night twist in the siren
sells 34 saves for Jeremy swan